some reason today during the count if
we're not able to launch
we do have a backup opportunity tomorrow
at 2 39
p.m eastern time
as i mentioned earlier today we are
launching from the historic launch pad
39a
this is the same launch pad responsible
for sending nasa astronauts to the moon
in the 1960s
and more recently helping bring human
space flight back to the united states
after the conclusion of the space
shuttle program in 2011.
less than two weeks ago spacex launched
its third human spaceflight mission
with a flight proven booster and dragon
spacecraft from this very pad
this time we had four crew members on
board those were nasa astronauts
shane kimbrough and megan macarthur
european space agency astronaut
thomas pesquet and japan aerospace
exploration
agency astronaut aki hoshide that was
the start of the six-month crew 2
mission
to the international space station and
just eight days later
after spending 167 days in space
the crew won astronauts returned to
earth on sunday may 2nd
making their journey the longest
duration mission for u.s spacecraft
since the final skylab mission in 1974
with nasa astronauts mike hopkins victor
glover
and shannon walker aboard as well as
jaxa astronaut
soichi naguchi dragon autonomously
undocked from the international space
station
at 8 35 pm eastern daylight time on
saturday may 1st
spacecraft performed a series of
departure burns to move away from the
orbiting laboratory
you can actually see here those draco
thrusters firing on
the dragon spacecraft
we spent a little bit of time in orbit
and then
the had an opportunity to come back to
earth
the spacecraft re-entered the earth's
atmosphere deployed its two drogue
shoots and four main shoots in
preparation for soft
water landing and upon splashdown spacex
quickly recovered dragon from the water
as well as the crew one astronauts
now this was the first nighttime
splashdown of a u.s spacecraft
with crew on board since apollo 8 in
1968.
now the crew as you can see we're pretty
happy healthy and really seem to enjoy
the ride aboard dragon
it's been a fantastic couple of weeks
for the human space flight program and
the team here at spacex
is honored to have been a part of it now
we are just
at t minus five minutes away from
liftoff falcon 9 is now moving into the
final stages of its countdown
we're currently awaiting the transporter
erector or te
retraction the transporter erector is
that structure
the white structure to the left of the
vehicle
it provides liquids gases and electrical
connections to the second stage as well
as air conditioning
to the payload and at about
or just about now actually we should
start to see the transporter erector
beginning its retract progress
process so first we'll see that clamp
that you can see right underneath the
payload fairing starting to retract
and then shortly after the transporter
erector will
move away from the vertical position to
about two degrees away from the vertical
and finally around t minus zero
hydraulics will pull away the
transporter erector farther from falcon
9 clearing the way
for it to ascend
at this point the first stage is nearly
fully loaded with a million pounds of
kerosene fuel and liquid oxygen
and i add here for the transport erector
now on the right side of the vehicle
should start to retract away shortly
now super chilled liquid oxygen you can
actually see some of the
gas clouds forming from that's our
propellant oxidizer it forms those white
clouds around the rocket
as it comes into contact with the moist
florida atmosphere we're constantly
topping up the propellant in these final
minutes until liftoff
and the small oxygen vents overboard to
form these clouds
this transporter erector retracting to
that two degree position
coming up in about 15 seconds we should
hear a call out
for prop loading complete on the first
stage
strong by glorious
then coming up shortly after that will
actually be a call out for the second
stage completing its prop loading
expect that call around t minus two
minutes
you can see a little bit of the wind
there um still gentle enough for ascent
today
now after t minus two minutes the uh
next activity will be
at t minus 60 seconds that's when falcon
9
will transition into startup that's when
uh falcon 9's internal flight computers
will take over
the countdown until
essentially through the rest of the
mission
again next activity here is prop load
closeout
on the second stage
locks and fuel load is complete
that falcon 9 from a prop perspective is
ready to go
team's still not working any issues on
falcon 9.
that venting you're seeing there is
nominal uh again that's
liquid oxygen uh from the transporter
erector
in the lines in the transporter erector
that we're venting and as it comes into
contact
with the warm florida atmosphere into a
gas
humidifier and forms clouds with the
humidity
at florida
coming up transition into startup
shortly after
we'll hear a final poll from the launch
director
giving their go for launch
flight computers in startup
falcon 9 starlink ld is go for launch
fantastic news so with that launch teams
in the vehicle looking healthy
ready to go for launch t-minus 30
seconds to go why don't we listen
to the challenge for falcon 9 taking our
star links to orbit
t-minus 15 seconds
10 nine eight seven
six five four three
two one zero ignition
and lift off
vehicle is pitching downrange
t plus 40 seconds into flight falcon 9
has successfully lifted off from our pad
39a at the kennedy space center
carrying a stack of starlink satellites
into orbit
coming up we have just throttled down
for the point of
maximum dynamic pressure or max q
that's when we experience the highest
structural loads on the vehicle
as from the combination of how fast
we're moving through the earth's
atmosphere
falcon 9 is supersonic increasing our
velocity as the density of the
atmosphere
continues to decrease
max q that we are through the highest
structural loads on the vehicle
uh upcoming in about a minute we'll have
three events happening back to back
first of those will be main engine
cutoff or miko that's where we will
shut down all nine of those merlin 1d
engines to slow down the vehicle
in preparation for stage separation
that's the next event where the first
started and second stages will separate
stage one's starting to make its way
back down to landing
and stage two will continue on with the
third event second engine start number
one
or ses one that's where the merlin
vacuum engine will ignite and then
continue to propel the second stage
along with the payload to orbit
you heard the call there for mvac engine
chill that means we've started flowing a
small amount of propellant into the
turbo pumps
on the maryland vacuum to prepare it for
the full flow of when we
perform second engine start
so coming up shortly about two and a
half minutes into flight main engine
cutoff
followed by stage separation and then
shortly after
second engine start number one
stage separation confirmed
left-hand side of your screen you can
see the view from the first stage
interstage grid fins
starting to deploy uh second engine
start complete on the right-hand side
that glow of the maryland vacuum engine
shortly we'll see fairing deployment
bearing separation concern you from
inside the fairing halves you can see
them separating away from the vehicle
now as a reminder we will be recovering
that oh awesome you can see a view there
of one of the fairing halves
from going on back to earth for recovery
as a reminder we will be attempting to
recover both halves with a contracted
vessel named
sheila bordelon
first stage left-hand side of your
screen grid fins
are fully deployed at this point
those periodic bursts of white gas that
you see are from our attitude control
system
so the attitude control system giving
some small pulse of nitrogen gas
reorienting the stage to get the engines
down
and the heat shield down for its
upcoming events
second stage burn continuing to look
nominal
now the acquisition signal bermuda while
the second stage is continuing
on to orbit its first stage has a couple
of activities in order to make its way
back to earth
first is an entry burn it'll ignite
three of its m1d or merlin 1d engines
that helps to slow down the vehicle as
we start re-entering the upper parts of
the earth's atmosphere
the next event will be just before
touchdown on the drone ship that is a
landing burn
we'll ignite just a single center merlin
engine
and that's what will bring the vehicle
speed rapidly down
to zero for a soft touchdown on the
drone ship
you can see the first stage reorienting
on the left-hand side of your screen
both stages continue to follow nominal
trajectories
fantastic news from the navigation
officer that we're on our planned
trajectories
now the first stage is targeting our
drone ship named of course i still love
you which is stationed
off the east coast of florida and the
atlantic ocean
will view looking out of the inner stage
not too long ago we had a second stage
engine in there
which is what you see now on the right
hand side of your screen
now the grid fins which are those
waffle-like structures that you see
around the vehicle
those are more important once we get
into the earth's atmosphere we use those
to guide and direct
the first stage towards our drone ship
and so as we start getting more
atmospheric pressure and force as the
density of the atmosphere picks up
and our altitude drops those grid fins
start to gain author control authority
and help direct the first stage on its
trajectory
coming up shortly the left-hand side of
your screen for stage entry burn
that burn expected to last about 20
seconds we'll be
igniting three of the merlin engines
on the first stage to slow down the
vehicle
in preparation for atmospheric
entry
stage one flight termination system has
saved
stage one entry burn startup
you can see the plume of the merlin one
engines
getting pushed back from how fast the
stage is moving rapidly decelerating
stage one entry burn shutdown
a successful shutdown of those merlin to
follow nominal trajectories
successful shutdown of those merlin 1d
engines
next burn on the first stage will be at
just after t
plus eight minutes
that'll be the landing burn start just a
single
merlin engine there and
around the time that the first stage
should touch down on our drone ship
the second stage will also conclude its
burn
with an event called the seco one or
secondary engine cut off number one
stage one transonic
call out there for transonic meaning
that we are starting to
pick up speed in the earth's atmosphere
sort of in that in between range between
subsonic and supersonic
meaning faster supersonic meaning faster
than speed of sound
beautiful views stage 2 is in terminal
guidance planet earth
with our second stage merlin vacuum
engine on the right hand side
page one landing burn startup of the
landing burn
you can see the drone ship on our screen
stage one landing leg deploy
looks like we're coming right down on
target
now listen out here for secondary engine
cutoff
[Applause]
stage one lane there's a first stage
on the left-hand side of your screen
ninth recovery for this booster
termination system has saved
80 seconds successful recovery of an
orbital class rocket and cico called out
at the same time
meaning the second stage engine has also
shut down navigation officer will be
doing a check
orbit insertion and we are in a nominal
orbit
so at that second stage is going to
coast in this orbit for the next about
35 minutes
while that's happening uh you can take a
look at this animation to see where we
are in our coast phase we'll be coming
back here for a very
short relight of the second stage engine
to get into our payload deployment orbit
that'll be at about t plus 45 minutes i
hope to see you back then
acquisition a signal new finland
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
expected lots of signal for beta
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this
expect a glass of signal new finland
do
acquisition of signal good nelly
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
inspect the plastic signal i can tell
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
acquisition of signal to your google
search
do
[Music]
[Music]
i'm back engine chill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to our starlink webcast now
if you're just joining us we had a
successful liftoff at 301
pm eastern time from pad 39a in florida
successfully recovered our first stage
for the ninth time
and we're awaiting the relight of our
second stage engine for second engine
start number two
coming up just in a couple of seconds
burn going to be very short burn just
one second
and that will help raise our apogee and
perigee
into the payload deployment orbit
listen out here for the callouts
hopefully we'll get a shot of the second
stage's engine
for that ignition
short pulse you can see on your screen
there second engine start number two and
co2
navigation officer we'll see how our
orbit
ended up nominal payload deploy orbit
insertion
fantastic so with that we have another
15 minutes or so to this coast phase
before we deploy
our starling satellites into orbit now
during this 15 minute period
the second stage will begin a small spin
along its central axis
that's to give those starling satellites
enough momentum to space themselves out
shortly after payload deployment so
while we're getting ready for payload
deploy sit back
enjoy the space tunes and we'll see you
back here at t plus one hour and three
minutes 30 seconds
for payload deployment
has
[Music]
do
expected loss to signal to your cougars
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you